[Aplausos]
quatro pontos têm a minha religião faço
deles a minha filosofia e faça deles a
minha ação viva creia ame e faça essa é
também a minha oração
viva sua filosofia ame a sua arte creia
na sua religião e faça sua parte mas não
é sua religião para tentar reprimir o
outro somos 7 bilhões e mentes no mundo
e queria que todo mundo acredite na
mesma coisa é no mínimo papo de louco eu
respeito todos os que têm fé
eu respeito todos os que não a têm eu
respeito quem criei um deus eu respeito
quem não tem ninguém eu gosto de quem
tem fé no universo eu gosto de quem tem
em si mesmo
eu gosto de quem tem fé no verso eu
gosto dos que andam mesmo um abraço pra
quem é da ciência um abraço pra quem é
de deus
um abraço pra quem é da arte e um abraço
pra quem é ateu axé para quem é de axé
amém para quem é de amém psdb para quem
é de magia e amor para quem é do bem
intolerância religiosa a própria
contradição religião vem do latim
religar e que significa união então para
dividir o mundo entre os que vão os que
não vão para o paraíso o nosso mundo
está doente em tudo enquanto nós
perdemos tempo brigando por isso ao
invés de dividir as religiões em
transmissão do mal ea questão do bem que
tal bottas ideologia no bolso e ajudar
aquele moço que de frio morre na rua e
desamparados em ninguém
os grandes mestres já disseram que
precisamos de união então por que não
fazer do respeito também uma religião
ei
esse poema ele nasceu de uma reflexão
minha sobre o quanto é necessário a
gente incorporar valores humanos nossas
práticas de fé como respeito por exemplo
e eu acredito que as religiões na
verdade e ela deverão aflorar a gente
essas coisas aflorar a gente as nossas
virtudes aflorar agentes valores humanos
que faz a gente ser uma família na terra
então esse poema ele nasceu disso pra
falar disso para falar que a gente pode
se unir que todo mundo tem direito de
ser o que é que está tudo bem e que a
gente não precisa brigar por isso eu
acredito que a gente pode aprender com
todas as religiões em todas as
filosofias de vida do mundo que a gente
quiser aprender
o único problema na minha percepção é
quando essas ferramentas que deveriam
deveriam ser de desenvolvimento humano
elas começam a ser ferramenta de
manipulação social isso é perigoso ea
gente tem que ficar atento com isso mas
é muito fácil a gente perceber quando a
gente está indo por um caminho de
evolução ou quando a gente está indo por
um caminho que nos atrasa
nunca nem o que atrasa você vai ter
tolerância você vai ter preconceito você
vai ter raiva você vai ter o ódio em
nome de um deus ou deuses num caminho
que evolui a gente vai ter a união a
gente vai ter respeito
a gente vai ter consciência a gente vai
estar junto ele vai se tornar uma
família
então eu acredito que tudo depende como
a gente vai agir diante dessas coisas
esse poema é depois que eu publiquei ele
aconteceram coisas muito maravilhosa
comigo por exemplo aqui e muito feliz de
estar aqui e eu conheci muitas pessoas
eu fui a muitos lugares e pretende
conhecer muitas outras pessoas e por
causa desse poema
então acredito que é uma mensagem que
precisava chegar de alguma maneira até
as pessoas e isso é muito bom
sempre quando as pessoas vêm falar
comigo sobre esse poema elas falam algo
tipo
nossa eu não sabia que a gente pensava
assim no mundo
nossa mas se todo mundo pensasse como
você né
o tipo de ouvir me deu esperança e eu
fico muito feliz e muito agradecida por
poder da esperança pra alguém de algum
jeito
mas eu acho que todo mundo não tem que
pensar como eu a gente tem que estar
unido respeito só isso
e quando as pessoas vêm falar isso eu
fico sempre pergunta
quando o que será que faz a gente perder
a esperança será que faz a gente parar
de acreditar que mudanças são possíveis
que mudanças são reais
a gente não tivesse esperança um evento
como esse não teria sentido
então as mudanças são reais são
possíveis mas nós somos agentes ativos
nas mudanças que a gente quer ver no
mundo então se você quer mudança no
mundo você precisa fazer alguma coisa
pelas mudanças acontecerem e nos meus
textos meus poemas
eu gosto de falar de temas que são
importantes pra mim e que eu acredito
tem uma relevância para as outras
pessoas então educação religião arte são
assuntos que interessam muito tudo que
tem a ver com desenvolvimento humano
tudo que eu acredito que é melhor a
gente me interessa muito
então vou estar pra vocês um trecho de
um outro poema meu no educar para
florescer
eu quero ser a paciência porque eu sei
que a educação é uma forma de
resistência eu não vou mudar o mundo
porque sei fazer um verso o mundo muda a
todo instante a transformação constante
é uma lei do universo mas em tudo que
focamos aumenta a proporção eu vou focar
no bem na lucidez na razão eu não vou me
deixar levar por essa realidade
distorção que diz que deve esconder se
aquele que está fora do padrão porque o
padrão é um quadrado onde a natureza não
cabe o poder que me criou criou a flor
criou o pássaro criou a árvore do lado
de fora eu posso até fazer o sistema que
é de mim mas no meu interior
o pássaro que bate asas vai querer voar
até o fim e eu desejo que vou ii
[Aplausos]